a defeat for opponents of the
government's rwanda programme at least
in the short term the uk high court says
next tuesday's flight deporting the
first group of asylum seekers to kigali
can go ahead
pro-refugee groups had argued the policy
was unlawful and they were backed in
court on friday by the un refugee agency
the unhcr
she outlined the hopelessness
of the judicial system
in rwanda it doesn't have facilities it
doesn't have lawyers it doesn't have
interpreters it simply doesn't have the
capacity to deal with this but of course
that is not the issue
the fact is that rwanda is unsafe it's a
place where any opposition
to the current government is often
locked up
we don't want to see refugees locked up
we want to see refugees look after
safety
but the judge here said it was important
the home office be able to implement
immigration control decisions he's
allowed the groups to appeal though
that's going to happen on monday
all along the government's accepted that
there would be legal challenges to its
plan while insisting it would soon be
sending people to rwanda but it's still
possible it could face a wider judicial
review including into whether rwanda in
fact is a safe country to send
vulnerable people
the uk and rwanda announced the
agreement back in april the first stages
involved a payment of more than 150
million dollars to the rwandan
government
the british government hopes the scheme
will deter people from crossing the
english channel from france in small
boats last year 28 000 people made the
dangerous journey so far this year more
than 10 000 people have done so but
experts doubt that the rwanda scheme
will change much
the uk government has already
implemented a range of
what have been described as hostile
environment policies towards migrants
and asylum seekers and these have not
deterred
people from crossing borders and on the
contrary reducing legal goals for um for
claiming asylum
increases the the the undocumented rules
for now the flights to rwanda can in
theory begin in the next few weeks
opponents of the rwanda scheme will try
to convince the courts that the entire
policy is unlawful nadim baba al-jazeera
london